with peter and myself disabled our ideas
are out the window so we're gonna have
to rely on mark and sean to help us
create these games in two hours it just
works
how is this happening
no no that's what i thought why didn't
you know this don't mind the gap don't
mind the game don't mind the gap
[Music]
all righty well over the last few years
peter and myself have been learning
unreal engine while we've been usually
using it for filmmaking today that all
changes we saw
an opportunity for a little challenge
we're going to compete in developing a
game now we're going to only have a few
hours for this so there's going to be a
little bit of pressure here why don't we
give this challenge a little spin
oh well let's cut right to it
high five
[Music]
so the doctors were able to reattach our
hands thankfully but they said we need
at least a year to even get any feeling
back in our hands so i still want to
make this game yeah me too uh do you
know anybody who could help us out i
happen to know a famous youtube
personality who's incredibly interested
in learning unreal engine and he might
be able to help us is he in the studio
right now he is he's here with us right
now you may have seen him before
i wow
you know obviously i don't have hands
but i see you've got two ones right
there yeah
you've been saying you want to learn
unreal so i think it's finally time yeah
big video game fan yeah for years on my
channel like i really want to get into
the weeds of it you know and like i mean
you're great because you know what a
good video game is
so like you probably could make one
right oh yeah absolutely yeah i feel
like if i'm able to like critique
something harshly over and over and over
again enough that i'll be able to make
something amazing and that's what my
parents did yeah yeah so you guys are
gonna be working together yeah yeah i
think it'll be great do you think i
could have some help too or are you
going to be busy with
is there anyone else i guess there's um
marco are you doing anything right now
this is our intern mark
no mark can you could we steal you for
the day if you don't if you don't have
anything to do yeah yeah i know yeah i
would i would love to cool yeah do you
have any interest in making games
okay okay when did you uh when did you
get in town
a couple of minutes ago
you didn't like tell me beforehand you
were coming in
well you don't know unreal engine this
is perfect because you're like an intern
and he's an intern so you guys we're
gonna probably work really well together
sam i've been working here for six years
i i feel like i'm not an intern at this
point
yeah well you know it you know it never
leaves you though are you an intern now
no no no no he's a guest he's a guest
today interns yeah ow
all right we have our new teams we have
a new plan with peter and myself
disabled our ideas are out the window so
we're gonna have to rely on mark and
sean in both of their hands and their
minds to help us create these games
in two hours we have one million dollars
put in the expo
yeah
i am terrified because
i don't know anything about this and
looking at the menu it looks like
there's a bajillion things you can do
is finally learning unreal after
months of being here i've been here for
a month and a half i've done a lot of
cleaning i've done a lot of maintenance
i've done a lot of like subterfuge um
but i have not done a lot of learning
visual effects which is kind of like the
whole purpose of me here actually
specifically it's just unreal engine
this is the first time someone's down to
walk through unreal with me
i know this is a big moment for you
and you have to get over it because we
have to keep moving through this
yes
breathe
nice okay take your emotions yeah
pretend there's a bottle right here yeah
bottle them down can you hold my hand
all right gamers two hours begins now
is this two hours until finished game
time
yes sir all right go let's just let's go
we're making a new project from scratch
oh god so we're gonna do the third
person template got it now down here
let's name your game you you could name
it whatever you want i mean what do you
think i should name it okay well my
great project is always a classic name's
like the most important thing yeah
everyone knows this mark great name
peter great name yeah
meter meter park park
park meat park meat park
thoughts
done i don't love it so if you click
that that will run your game
and now click there and now this is
basic wasd controls and you can jump
what kind of like ass size can i do on
this character
oh [ __ ] that was like literally we knew
you were gonna say something about that
where's the butt sliders okay just
keep that keep that keep that in your
pocket keep that in your pocket how hard
is it to make an endless runner it's
kind of tough i mean what if there's a
template for it in the marketplace
there could be
there you go five dollars oh endless
running creator oh
let's throw out the third person
template and we're gonna use the endless
runner template instead
jokes on them there's no ends to this
game
what what challenges do you want to
throw at mark what's a game that is not
broken
yet unbeatable
his biggest fear is the ocean okay once
he's in the water what's going to get
him
uh shark
is he trying to get up to the surface
and breathe up
and if he doesn't get there in time he
drowns the main element is stress
what do you where should we go with this
it's a blank slate
okay so he's saying i know him very well
yeah i know him we've known each other
for many years we've talked many times
really gotten to know each other he's
irish
hey what do irish like
what do they you should know we've been
friends for like eight years
maybe even longer it's just for me
because i don't know
he'll tell you
all right
for the big buns here we go add sphere
so drag it and attach it to your mesh
okay and pelvis
pelvis
and there you go that's good
cool oh
so there you go
let's go
i know that he's going to get distracted
by this that i'll play i'll put in the
cheeks he'll play the game he'll be so
distracted by the sheer amount of that
ass that's on screen
that he won't want to play anything so
we're collecting assets right now we're
looking for irish stereotypes such as
leprechauns possible stop it
that's racist no no no you don't
understand you don't understand
anti-racist it is actually it's cultural
appreciation so the idea is to avoid the
stereotypes but when you hit the
stereotypes it adds the stereotypes to
your character and the more stereotypes
you have
the less health you have and then if you
get too many you die we're focusing on
stereotypes because we're breaking
history so much deeper than you think it
is you don't understand you have no idea
where we're even coming from pinta
guinness perfect potato feel free
um leprechaun that's good for 15
that's pretty good though that's great
look at the texture of the grain on the
wood personally if you're really
connected to it we can get it but i
don't think we need it
i think we need it
all right gamers 30 minutes has passed
what we're trying to do is decrease the
gravity of our jump to make it feel
underwatery
i thought that was easy
i was like oh there's a thing that's
like oh your jump lasts x frames let's
just increase the
did i do that yeah
you gave me a brilliant idea close out
of this character movement there it is
look gravity scale max acceleration
breaking friction why didn't you know
this look i couldn't see it it was
hidden you didn't scroll down far enough
try jumping oh
boy
so so we have all of our assets now we
have all of our irish
stereotype assets uh and we're just
going to extract them get them into
unreal and set them up for the game but
you don't even need to do anything yup
you just find something in the store
that has already done the thing that you
want to do and then you
modify it you you just take someone
else's work you re-skin it and then you
publish it as your own you know all
these artists are worried about like oh
ai is going to take over everything
people have just been stealing work
anyway like what's the what's the
difference for thousands of years we're
not doing anything new here i just want
like a shark like coming at him how do
we like rig a new blueprint to just
come at him you're in luck
i happen to have already guessed that
you were gonna want these assets okay so
can we go to the store are you taking
your shirt
we get to go shopping i got two assets
for you
yes yes there's a great white shirt
i'm not yelling it because i don't want
him to know surprise is the key here now
go down a little further
reef kit all right there we go
we're under water we got our setting
what's our challenge
okay so the shark is like circling from
the beginning like in the distance going
around then he realizes oh that's my
enemy if we can like hide like a
a rescue like button or something
somewhere he hits the button
his cheeks inflates but it carries him
to the surface yes perfect that's it all
right
great so it's like so it's like a needle
no no not a note it's like a syringe
full of like button yeah it's like
synthol
sun runner go to blueprints that's where
all the code will be blueprints okay so
we can click on that and replace it with
a different mesh okay yep oh great
whoa yeah
basically
done yeah so if we hit play
it just works
how does this happen
you don't know you're the teacher i
didn't code this
just drag that out into our area here
and now we have a reference to this so
from here we can start to draw out
different qualities of it scripting yes
so what's gonna happen is he hits this
thing yeah butt pops all right cheeks in
flight
and then basically what we're gonna do
is the character gets turned into a set
simulate physics uh mode basically where
it ragdolls yeah and then as we do that
we're gonna gradually apply velocity to
that pelvic bone in the ragdoll from a
physics standpoint we're just going to
be adding a vertical force
to that butt area
on the bone so we're doing ass inflation
all right
it's like a rocket yeah it's like a butt
rocket that's like it adds fuel to my
inflated ass yeah it's like a like you
light up lighter behind your butt and
you fart what does it look like if i
just do one
let's see what one looks like
that's the exact same okay that's not
okay um
you guys doing okay over there oh yeah
you guys yeah that's great if you guys
need help with anything just let us know
no because we got fun we're we're
playing fortnite right now yeah
okay cool yeah they just had a goku so
all right gamers that's the halfway
point one hour left
so we're trying to replace these pillars
with the plank character that we bought
we can select our little plank guy plank
guy
we got our planks in there also i feel
like it's kind of hard to see the face
maybe we should oh we can add a light to
it oh yeah
illuminate the face so you can see the
smiley face better on the plank that we
spent 15 on
well we didn't you did well you'll pay
me back right yeah
okay yeah okay yeah
okay um but yeah now we have a little
light
why is it so difficult to make someone's
ass go up yeah so let's just do add
impulse mesh there we go there we go i
think this might be it so give us a 20
on the z axis there 20 on the z all
right and let's hit play let's go okay
please
make your ass go up
the same thing happened
we're trying to have it so that when the
player overlaps with one of these
stereotypes it gets applied to them and
like snaps onto them but we're having
trouble having the player interact with
these stereotypes it's not recognizing
when it's hitting them it is a child of
the pillar does that give it any
properties the hat might not have
collision yet
auto convex collision we can get rid of
print strings yes and we basically like
on this attach component put that in
there author comp to the parent yes and
then keep world yes
that was already set and then yes
boom dude and then
this guy
[Laughter]
yes no way is it our spears is it our
butt cheeks
don't you [ __ ] dare all right here
try that try it select our sphere one
and sphere two collision presets says
block all dynamic switch that to no
collision now try it one more time
they could have been picking up
yes
yes good job all right this is working
all right let's go right to the butt
cheeks then all right
all right oh yeah all right all right so
let's save everything tell me how uh the
motion of the butt cheeks inflates i i
want their like hips to shatter when it
happens but just
you oh it's just
okay cool so
it's like an airbag you got any like
hentai reference like lying around
surely i do uh it's in my private
collection okay okay let's see if we get
big is this the moment yeah
it's like
it's pretty big uh is that what i think
that's perfect is that tasteful yeah
okay
only 15 minutes left better start making
those final touches okay great we need
to make these
power-ups make you go faster right yes
yes so if you get the power-ups you go
faster right okay connect those
execution pins and then drag the blue
into the blue
this should work hopefully this should
make it faster it's not quite no faster
it's just adding but not to the
it needs to add to this function
because it just sets the it sets the
movement to one movement's zero when
it's not doing anything so when it sets
to one it just goes one it needs to
change that the multiplication factor
because if it changes the multiplication
factor to this you're so right yes yes
okay oh
yes go down to dead that has to be
checked that wasn't checked
yeah that was that was it it was just
that all right
you're gonna die
eat [ __ ] and die let's run the game
let's take a look is that clear
[Music]
they're going we're going up yeah
they're still going up yeah that's
working final minutes
we just gotta you gotta get this
collision right is the gap if we don't
don't mind yeah don't mind the gap don't
mind the gap it does not matter it's
just a little bit matters
you need to save it and got to be
playable 45 seconds escape excuse me
we're going to find the hole quick atom
pulse set that to five instead of one
this one right there all right we're
done
all right gamers walk away put it down
all right that's it
hands up
that was a lot of doing yeah that was
stressful
oh that was stressful
meat park is going to take the world by
storm look dude this is a functional
game it's going to sell
we're good people are going to talk
about it for years it's going to win
baftas
peter i we set out to make games and
technically we did technically yes
correct i want to i want to play each
other's games so we play yours first
sure sure
this is a world unlike any other world
you've seen before does this feature the
reef kit
your favorite
so we set this all in underwater there's
only one way out of this ocean and your
big cheeks are your ticket to ride okay
i'm ready i'm yeah
[Music]
that's incredible
the environment is very dense you know
it that's the power of this kid yeah
that's the power of the reef the reef
kit is really people don't realize how
strong the reef is
is that my oxygen
yeah yeah it's your timer okay uh-huh
okay so you said i had an ability right
your
my cheeks didn't save me no no no you
have to find something sharp the problem
look around look behind you
is there anyone else here with you why
would there be
i think you messed something up mark
yeah what did you press i oh
are you stuck whoa
[Laughter]
wow
and your cheeks
saved the day big stinker that's amazing
that was actually cool
intuitive game design is what we're all
about it's not too easy but our yeah our
chica our cheek inflation system is very
robust this is all custom built like
proprietary yeah
[Music]
great work john thank you excellent job
i
i mean it's it's not necessarily about
how it looks it's about how it makes you
feel yeah exactly
think of your childhood okay young irish
lad
dealing with the
bullying how many times did you did you
hear hey potato boy or hey guinness guy
well you and your red hair get over here
and drink this guinness
i can't believe you have to put up with
that no no no no no no
yeah we feel your pain
we feel it maybe even more than you feel
it i i have irish blood in me surging
through my veins right now so i in some
way feel your pain wait your last name
is france
it's a complicated story we're trying to
break down the walls
of these stereotypes that are harmful
untrue you've never eaten a potato you
don't drink guinness who does
it does not taste good avoid the
stereotypes because they are
uh inaccurate and bad
wow
[Music]
avoid these stereotypes at all costs
yeah avoid them oh god oh
my god okay
[Applause]
so no don't hit them i'm gathering my
heritage these stereotypes is you know
they really stick with you when when you
when you encounter them i see
i like your menu system thank you we we
made that i like your did you make this
from scratch yes the problem with this
is that i don't dislike leprechauns then
hit him you go faster yeah yeah yeah
yeah you'll go faster it's you know it
can if you embrace
[Music]
look at all these leprechauns you're
collecting
this is this endless is this all like
procedural no there's an energy there's
an end try to beat it
wow this is this is we've never gone
this far this is incredible you haven't
even been in your own game this is
beyond us
wow look at all those lips
it's impossible this is broken what do
you mean he's just not good enough we
have something else you can play
something else
we had enough time we made two games oh
my god
yeah actually we made eight wait this is
just a
you didn't make this what are these
other games interesting so uh what about
irish history are we seeing here these
people you can see the gold um yeah the
gold
butter gold irish gold
butter yes amazing game
thank you thank you so many very awesome
beautiful thank you that 15 plank of
wood
was used really well thank you feeling
real proud of my heritage right now yes
amazing we did it
i love making games and i love making
them from scratch and i love
when you know you don't need to like
rely on like pre-made assets to make an
awesome game here you know you just kind
of coat it from the ground up the fact
that you could get the unreal default
mannequin running and jumping around was
just amazing yeah isn't that so
incredible crazy
i learned so much in just two hours
legitimately like going into the
blueprint system going into like
changing material properties suddenly
all those like rgb things made sense i'm
like oh i get it now there's way more to
it than i thought like that i knew like
the nodes and everything like putting
them all together and creating your own
logic and everything was like as complex
as you wanted to be but
even just basic stuff was really hard to
do you know we should do this again
sometime if you guys have an idea for
another unreal challenge we could do
please leave it in the comments guys
guys comment with the word subscribe if
you like this video